>>> WE'RE FOLLOWING BREAKING
NEWS.
TWO CO-HOSTS OF "THE VIEW" HAVE
JUST TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
HERE'S THE KEY -- THIS IS
MOMENTS BEFORE VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS WAS SCHEDULED TO
APPEAR IN A LIVE INTERVIEW ON
SET WITH THEM.
NAVARRO AND HOSTIN WERE TAKEN
OFF THE SET.
WE WANT TO PLAY THE MOMENT THIS
WAS ANNOUNCED.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO SINCE THIS IS GOING TO BE
A MAJOR NEWS STORY ANY MINUTE
NOW, WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT SONNY
AND ANNA BOTH APPARENTLY TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID NO MATTER HOW
HARD WE TRIED, THESE THINGS
HAPPEN.
THEY PROBABLY HAVE A
BREAKTHROUGH CASE AND THEY'LL BE
OKAY I'M SURE BECAUSE THEY'RE
BOTH VACCINATED UP THE WAZOO.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF VACCINES.
SO -- AND THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
BEING PREPPED FOR HER ARRIVAL,
RIGHT.
THEY CLEAN THE TABLE, WE A WERED
THE HANDS, EVERYBODY'S GETTING
CLEANED UP AND SHE'LL BE OUT
HERE IN A SECOND.
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, IT'S GOOD
TO HEAR ANNA AND SONNY ARE DOING
OKAY.
LET ME BRING IN BRIAN STELTER
AND JEREMY DIAMOND FOR MORE ON
THIS.
TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
LEARNING HAS HAPPENED.
>> THIS INTERVIEW WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN DERAILED
BECAUSE OF THE COVID TESTS AND
THE POSITIVE RESULTS.
NOW MAYBE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
INTERVIEW THE VICE PRESIDENT
REMOTELY.
BUT OBVIOUSLY IT'S A CONCERN
WHENEVER THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
AROUND FOLKS WHO HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID.
THAT IS WHY THERE ARE SO MANY
TESTS.
WHEN YOU'RE ON A SHOW LIKE "THE
VIEW" ON ABC YOU'RE GETTING
TESTED BEFORE YOU GO INTO THE
STUDIO.
SO THE HOST, YOU KNOW, RECEIVES
THEIR RAPID TEST AND APPARENTLY
LIVE DURING THE PROGRAM, DURING
THE HOUR, THEY RECEIVE THEIR
POSITIVE TEST RESULTS.
NOW, WE KNOW THERE ARE LOTS OF
THESE POSITIVE CASES AMONG
VACCINATED PEOPLE, MOST FOLKS
NEVER EVEN SHOW SYMPTOMS.
THAT'S ONE OF THESE SITUATIONS
WITH ANNA AND SUNNY, FEELING
JUST FIND, BUT IT TURNS OUT IN
THEIR NOSE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
COVID SO THEY WERE HAVING TO
LEAVE THE SET.
IT DOES DERAIL THE VICE
PRESIDENTIAL INTERVIEW AS A
RESULT.
THIS INTERVIEW WAS ON THE BOOKS
FOR WEEKS, KATE, A VERY BIG
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST FEMALE VICE
PRESIDENT ON THIS TALK SHOW
GEARED TOWARD WOMEN.
NOW WHO KNOW WHAT IS WILL
HAPPEN.
>> THE VIDEO WE'RE SHOWING
EVERYONE, THIS IS FROM THE SHOW
OPEN.
YOU SEE THAT ANNA AND SUNNY ARE
THERE AT THE DESK COMING OUT.
THEY WERE READY TO LET THIS PLAY
OUT.
JEREMY, WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE
ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, THEY DID CONFIRM TO ME
THAT INDEED THE VICE PRESIDENT
IS GOING TO BE DOING THIS
INTERVIEW BUT WILL BE DOING IT
REMOTELY FROM A STUDIO IN THE
BUILDING SEPARATE FROM THAT
LARGER STUDIO WHERE THE HOSTS
ARE AND WHERE ANA NAVARRO AND
SUNNY HOSTIN WERE SEATED MOMENTS
BEFORE THEY WERE TAKEN OFF OF
THAT SET.
WE ARE ALSO HEARING ACCORDING TO
A WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT DID NOT INTERACT
WITH ANA NAVARRO OR SUNNY HOSTIN
BEFORE THE SHOW.
SO THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT
SHE HAS BEEN EXPOSED OR THAT SHE
IS A CONTACT AS IT RELATES TO
BOTH OF THOSE WOMEN TESTING
POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS AN ABUNDANCE
OF CAUTION THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
IS TAKING THESE PRECAUTIONS TO
KEEP THE VICE PRESIDENT OUT OF
THE ROOM WHERE THE OTHER HOSTS
WHOCH NOT TESTED POSITIVE BUT
WHO WERE CLEAR HI IN CONTACT
WITH ANNA AND SUNNY ARE STILL
SEATED.
LOOK, THE WHITE HOUSE TAKES --
UNDERGOES A LOT OF PRECAUTIONS
AS IT RELATES TO THE PRESIDENT
AND VICE PRESIDENT.
JEN PSAKI, THE PRESS SECRETARY,
TOLD ME THE PRESIDENT IS
REGULARLY TESTED AND SAME
APPLIES FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT,
AND PEOPLE WHO INTERACT WITH
THEM IN CLOSE QUARTERS ARE ALSO
REGULARLY TESTED.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS POOL, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHEN TRAVELING, SMALL
GROUP OF REPORTERS, FRACHERS WHO
TRAVEL WITH THE PRESIDENT OR WAS
IN THE ROOM WITH THE PRESIDENT
IN THE OVAL OFFICE AND SMALLER
EVENTS, THEY ALSO MUST BE TESTED
ON THE DAY IN WHICH THEY ARE IN
THAT POOL.
SO THESE PRECAUTIONS ARE ONGOING
AND OF COURSE WE KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT, HE IS SET TO RECEIVE
HIS BOOSTER SHOT BECAUSE HE'S
OVER 65.
WE DON'T KNOW YET WHETHER THE
VICE PRESIDENT WILL RECEIVE A
BOOSTER SHOT, BUT I WOULD THINK
SHE WOULD APPLY OR THAT SHE
WOULD COME IN THE CATEGORY OF
FRONTLINE WORKERS IT INTO TOLD
THAT SHOT.
>> ONE THING THIS SHOWS IS T